اذا بدعوه من العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز يزوروا الرئيس الصيني
السعوديه في زياره رسميه تستمر ثلاثه ايام
حيث ستعقد قمه سعوديه صينيه واخرى خليجيه
صينيه وثالثه عربيه
وسيعقد العهد السعودي ورئيس الصيني
محادثات رسميه تتناول العلاقات الثنائيه
وشاركه الاستراتيجيه التي تجمع البلدين
واجد سفر الصيني لدى السعوديه
علاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله وفقه
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط واشار السفير في ذات
الصدد الى ان العالم سيشهد او لا قيمه من
طاقه بين الصين ودول العربيه وبين الصين
ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي على مستوى
القاده
كيمياء وغير مخفيه تجمع الرياض وبكين سرعت
عجله التعاون العسكري والاقتصادي التي
سبقت التقطير السياسيه الكامله بينهما
تركيبه العلاقه بين البلدين تعود جزئيتها
لمجموعه من الدوافع المتبادله فاولويات
العلاقه مع الشريك الصينيه تتمثل بالتعاون
غير المشروط اي غياب اي شروط صينيه في
الانفتاح على مزيد من افاق التعاون بين
الجانبين
الاولويه
المملكه على الصين ليس استثناء بل يدخلوا
ضمن سياسه التوسع شرقا واستراتيجيه تعدد
البدائل والتحالفات وان كان بمستويات
متفاوته الا ان الصين استحوذت على الحصه
الكبرى لامكانياتها الاقتصاديه وموقعها
بمجلس الامن سياسه تبعت برسائل لبعض حلفاء
المملكه بعدم
رهن المصالح لخيارات دوله محدده مهما
كانتها ودمنا مزايا التعاون تدخل السوق
الصينيه المتعطشه للنفط ومصادر الطاقه في
الصين التي تعد رابع منتجا للنفط في
العالم تعتمد على الاستيراد كذلك بسبب
ارتفاع الطلبه اكثر من الانتاج المحليه
وهنا تاتي محاوله ابعاد الصين عن ايران او
على الاقل اضعاف في علاقتها بها وبالتالي
تقليل الحاجه الصينيه للنفت الايراني
وزياده ضغط العقوبات على طهران من جهتها
تستقطب السعوديه الاهتمام الصيني من منطلق
موقعها بالمنطقه العربي
ومركزيه قرارها فتعاون مع المملكه يطفي
مشروعيه على سياسه الصين الخارجيه وثقلها
بالمنطقه وما وزين القوه الدوليه كما يخلق
فرصا لتحسين صورتها بالعالم العربي
تعاون يصب ايضا في زاويه مستلزمات مشروعها
لاستراتيجي المتمثل بطريق الحرير بحكم
الموقع الجغرافي للسعوديه
وامكانياتها الماديه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من الرياضه
الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث اهلا بك وما بكين ديمونكا
صحفيه الصينيه اهلا بكمين اسمحالي ان ابدا
من الرياض معك دكتور عبد العزيز في الواقع
زياره سبقتها تصريحات رسميه الصينيه
الدكتور عبد العزيز تاكد على مكانه هذه
العلاقه السعوديه الصينيه وتؤكد كذلك على
مخرجات ستكون مفيده للطرفين ولكن بحسب
رايك ماذا في اولويات مضامين هذه الزياره
الدبلوماسيه
اول مساء الخير لك استاذ ريم ولا مشاهدينك
والضيفتك الكريمه من الصين سعداء هذا
اليوم في الرياض ان نستقبل الرئيس الصيني
والذي جاء بدعوه من خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الثلاثه قمم تبدا لهما غدا بين القمه
السعوديه الصينيه ويوم الجمعه القمه
الصينيه العربيه والقمه الصينيه الخليجيه
هذه القيمه من الثلاثه جاءت لتؤكد مكانه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الدوليه وتؤكد
ايضا على ان الصين ترى ان الرياض هي مركز
صناعه القرار المهمه هنالك علاقه اقتصاديه
قويه بين الصين والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودول الخليج وايضا مع الدول العربيه حيث
بلغ اجمالي الحجم التبادل التجاري مع
الدول العربيه 330 مليار دولار منها 220
مليار لوحده مع الدول الخليجيه والمملكه
تحتل مكان كبرى حوالي 87 مليار دولار فهذا
يؤكد على اهميه التعامل الاقتصادي الكبير
بين الصين والمنطقه هنا والتي نمت خلال
فتره مهمه جدا ان ايضا الاستثمارات
الصينيه في المنطقه ما بين عام
2021 بلغت اكثر من 220 مليار دولار وهذه
ايضا ارقام كبيره تؤكد على اهتمام الصين
بالمنطقه لان المنطقه لديها موارد طبيعيه
مهمه جدا الصين بحاجه لها تمثل طبعا الدول
الخليج والمملكه بالذات المصدر الاكبر
للطاقه حيث تبلغ حوالي نسبه 83% من
الصادرات الخليجيه الى الصينيه يعني في
قطاع الطاقه للدرجه الاولى ولكن ايضا
هنالك التوسع في هذه العلاقه في الصين
تريد ان تؤكد على انها ثاني اكبر اقتصاد
في العالم تعداد سكانها البالغ مليار و500
مليار نسمه
اقتصادياتها القويه تريد ايضا ان تؤكد على
اهميه علاقه هذه المنطقه بها وعلاقتها
بالمنطقه والدور الذي يمكن ان تقوم به
الصين مستقبلا ما زلت النظر الشخصيه ارى
ان هنالك دور سياسي ايضا مهم للصين هي ما
زالت علاقه اقتصاديه بامتياز ولكنها لم
تنتقل الى علاقه سياسيه في اوجه مختلفه
وكانت دائما الصين همم يعني تستخدم اسلوب
العلاقه المتوازنه ما بين الاطراف مع انه
الصين دوله عضو في مجلس الامن وعظم مهم
جدا ولها قوه وثقل كبير نرى انه هنالك
حاجه ان يكون اكثر وضوحا في بعض المواقف
بالنسبه للصين لاهميتها بالنسبه للمنطقه
العربيه والتي تعاني من اشكاليات كبيره
ومن تدخلات خارجيه من ليبيا الى سوريا الى
العراق الى لبنان الى اليمن الى العلاقه
مع ايران الصين مع الاسف في بعض الاحيان
نرى انها رخوه في علاقتها مع ايران ربما
لان ترى اهميه ايران بالنسبه لها من ناحيه
الموقع الجغرافي ومن ناحيه العلاقه ايضا
ودول الجوار المهمه مثل الباكستان
وافغانستان وهنالك علاقه اقتصاديه قويه
بين الصين وايران نحن لا نعترض على هذا
العلاقه ولكن ما يهمنا ويعنينا ان يكون
هنالك مواق صينيه واضحه تجاه هذه
الاعتداءات الايرانيه على المنطقه والتدخل
في شؤونها الداخليه دول المنطقه احترمت
الصين والوحده الصين والصين الموحد ولم
تتدخل في قضايا او ترفع اي شعارات من
شانها ان تغضب الصين لا في تايوان ولا
هونج كونج ولا موضوع ال ال الايجور ولا
موضوع يعني كل هذه القضايا ترى الدول
العربيه ان هذا شان صيني بحث هي من شان ان
تتعامل معه ولكن نرى ايضا اهميه ان يكون
هنالك علاقه قويه نحن ايضا لا نريد في
المنطقه العربيه ان تكون طرف في اي تنافس
امريكي
همم امكانيه ان تتوسع هذه العلاقه لتشمل
مجال السياسي كذلك اسمح لي ان انقل هذه
النقطه الضيف من بكين ديما ووند ديمه هل
ان التعاون
سيقتصر على ما تحدث به في السفير الصيني
همم لدى الرياض هو تحدث عن تعاون سيشمل
البنيه تحتيه الطاقه الامن الغذائي الصحه
التنميه الخضراء تاهيل الشباب بضيفي كذلك
دكتور عبد العزيز تحدث عن اهميه موضوع
الطاقه اا هل يمكن ان ينسحب كذلك على
ملفات سياسيه تعتقدين
همم
اعتقد ان التعاون بين سن و- اا السعوديه
في شتى المجدلات وخاصه في هذه هي سنوات
في مجال السياسيه والاقتصاديه وثقافيه
وتعليميه ومسيحيه وغيرها
لا اعتقد ان لا تنفع هذه التعاون الصين
فحسب بل ستساهم في
التعاون وتحقيق الاحداث التماريه المشترك
وخادمه المسارحه المتبادله وهذا ينفع
للجميع
ولكن لاحدد سؤالي اكثر كيف ترى الصين هذه
المنطقه همم لانه كانت العلاقات همم
اقتصاديه بامتياز هي علاقات متينه تاريخيه
ولكن هناك كذلك همم ملفات على الطاوله
وهناك كما تعلمين حضرتك تغيرات جيو سياسيه
متسارعه تشهدها المنطقه ويشهدها العالم
فقط وردتنا معك ان نفهم نظره الصين
المنطقه ان كانت عينها على بعض المصالح
فيما يخص هذا الملف بتحديد
تعتبروا دول العربيه الدول محمه على
توري مبادره لاحزام و طريق كما نعرف ان
المبادره على حزام وطريق
الذكي طرحها رئيس الحسينيه عام 2013
اه
ايضا ااا تقليد الشعب تقريبا قلوب الشعب
بين بلدان المختلفه
دكتور عبد العزيز ااا لماذا اتت هذه
الزيارات في هذا التاريخ بتحديد الاكيد
بان هناك دلالات كذلك للتوقيت ان تاتي
ثلاث قمم في وقت وجيز تقريبا متزامنا في
ثلاثه ايام لماذا في هذا التوقيت
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه استقبلت
الرئيس دونالد ترامب في بدايه وكان هنالك
قيمه كبيره مهمه وايضا استقبلت رئيس وكانت
قمه خليجيه ايضا عربيه هنا نريد ان يؤكد
ان هنالك علاقه مهمه مع الصين واستقبال
الرئيس الصيني وايجاد هذه القمم تؤكد اولا
على دور المملكه واهميته وتؤكد ايضا على
الاهتمام الصيني بالعلاقه مع مع الجانب مع
العالم العربي والسعوديه والرياض كم مركز
لصناعه القرار هذه نقاط اساسيه مهمه ايضا
هنالك رساله اخرى يعني نريد ان لدينا
علاقه متوازنه مع جميع الاطراف مثل ما
لدينا علاقه قويه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عن المستوى السياسي والامني
والاقتصادي وايضا نريد ان يكون لنا علاقه
قويه مع الصين كدوله كبرى ومهمه وهي
الاقتصاد الثاني والاكبر اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده اكثر من 21 تريليون
دولار حجم الناتج المحلي في الصين حوالي
17 ونصف مليون دولار وهذا مهم جدا انها
لها اقتصاد كبير تعداد هي الاكبر تعداد
سكان في العالم والاكثر نمو والتسارع في
النمو في الجانب الصيني فهذا ايضا يؤكد
على ان لدينا سياسه متوازنه في التعامل مع
كافه مع الاطراف حتى وان كان بين هذه
الاطراف نوع من الخلافه ومنوع من التنافس
نحن لا نريد ان نكون في المنطقه جزء من
هذا التنافس او الصراع وانما نريد ان تكون
لدينا مصالحنا وعلاقاتنا يعنيينه جدا
الموقف السياسي المستقبلي بالنسبه للصين
وهذا ما سوف يدعم
ويعزز التعاون الاقتصادي اذا كانت الموقف
السياسيه اكثر وضوحا في المستقبل يعني
هنالك الصين دائما في سوريا على سبيل
المثال يعني بقيت خلف الموقف الروسي في
بعض المواقف الثانيه حاولت ان تقول ان
لديها موقف يعني لم نستمع الى انتقاد صيني
واحد على الصواريخ البالستيه التي يطلقها
الحوثي وهو الحرب بالوكاله عن ايران في
المنطقه هنا على السعوديه نعم استمعنا الى
التصريح الصيني بانها ترحب بالادنه وتقبل
الهنا ولكن ايضا مواقف اكثر موضوع لانه
هذا ما نتوقع من دوله كبرى مثل الصين وعضو
في مجلس الامن ان تكون لديها مواقف صريحه
وواضحه دعم من الامن والاستقرار مثل ما
اقول سابقا لم نتدخل في الشان الصيني وفي
القضاء الصينيه ولكن ايضا هي ترفض التدخل
الامريكي فكيف تقبل هي التدخل الايراني في
منطقتنا دون ان يكون لها وجهه نظر واضحه
وصريحه في هذه الجوانب فسوف يعزز التنميه
الاقتصاديه ومشروع الطريق والحزام هو
المواقف السياسيه الواضحه التي يجب ان
تاخذها الصين تجاه قضايا المنطقه واهميتها
همم هو على كل هناك كما تعلم دكتور عبد
العزيز همم
مراقبين يقولون بان الصين حتى في موضوع
الحرب الاوكرانيه روسيه ليست لها تصريحات
هذه همم طريقه الصحيح في تعاملها
الدبلوماسي يعني هي تبقى تتابع تراقب
وفيما بعد ربما تطلق مواقفها بطريقه اكثر
وضوح ولكن فيما يخص هذه
لم تقدم اي سلاح لروسيا ولكنها ايضا حافظت
على علاقه قويه استفاده من الوضع الروسي
بشراء النفط بخصم يعني 30% على الاسعار
الموجوده هي ايضا تنظر الى مصالحها
الاقتصاديه بشكل جيد
الصين كذلك همم وهنا سؤال سيده ديما ما
الذي تريده الصين من هذه الزيارات
بالتحديد هل هناك اولويات على قائمتها
لانه السفر الصيني في الرياض تحدث عن ان
همم هناك همم سلسله وثائق ختاميه مهمه حول
نتائج هذه القيم ما الذي يمكن ان يفهم من
هذا التصريح
نعم والان العالم يشاهد الترابا كبيرا
واعتقد ان الصين ودولي العربيه تواجه
تحديات متشابهه فهو الوقت يحتاج فيه
التعاون بين البلدان مختلفه وخاصه بين
السن ودولي العربيه وكما نعرف ان
الصين ودوري العربيه
اقتصاديه وعلى سبيل المثال الدول العربيه
الى الموارد وطاقه
واصبحت واصبحت الدول العربيه احنوا منورين
السن حاليا هو هي اكبر شريط تجاريا في
دوري العربيه وكما
قال قبل قليل
السعودي ان اا تجاوز حجم التجاره بين
الصين ودول العربيه ااا 300 مليار دولار
في العام الماضي
على اثر هذه القمه سيكون هناك تعاون اضخم
واوسع سنقع في انتظار مخرجات هذه القيمه
الثلاثه ساكتفي معكم بهذا القدر على ان
نكون ربما في نقاشات اخرى ولكن في حلقات
لاحقه شكرا جزيلا من الرياضه دكتور عبد
العزيز بن صقر حيث مركز الخليج للابحاث
ومن بكين ديما وانجح الصحفيه الصينيه شكرا
لكم
نتوقف مع فاصل المشاهدين ان نعود من بعده
لنتابع
اجهاضم محاوله انقلابيه لخليه ارهابيه تم
تفكيكها واعتقاله عناصرها وقل السلطات
الالمانيه ما هذه الخليه لمن تنتمي لماذا
وصفت بالارهابيه وهل روسيا فعلا متورطه
معها